quelle place pour le numérique dans les
transports comment réduire les fractures
sociales et territoriales lié aux
mobilités des questions vastes et
complexes auxquels ont tenté de répondre
une cinquantaine de personnes à
versailles cet atelier territoriale
s'inscrit dans le cadre des assises de
la mobilité lancée en septembre par le
gouvernement
objectif imaginer et façonner les
futures politiques de transport chacun
des habitants à sa propre expérience de
mobilité et parfois ses propres
contraintes ou ses propres difficultés
et donc l'objectif c'est demande d'avoir
la concertation la plus large possible
pour arriver à définir tout ça ensemble
à versailles élus locaux membres
d'associations et habitant plancher sur
deux thématiques précises
comment rendre les mobilités plus
connectés et plus solidaire de quoi
nourrir de nombreuses réflexions
on aimerait développer par exemple à 7,1
un système d'auto stop
organisé comme un système de covoiturage
sauf que on connaît les gens
avant et puis ça développe un lien
social qui s'est dégagée principalement
concerne le rabattement des villes et
des airs périurbaines sur les gares et
les centre-villes avec toute une variété
de l'offre possible revaloriser d'avoir
plus d'informations sur
les transports disponibles que ces
informations soient disponibles de
manière unifiée sur une seule
application et qu'on puisse aussi dans
l'autre sens signifier sa présence les
assises de la mobilité se poursuivre en
france jusqu'en décembre
elles déboucheront sur un projet de loi
en début d'année prochaine